The Joe Rogan experience.
We were talking before this, uh, podcast started that you,
when you left Anthony,
you went and decided to do your own thing behind a pay wall. Yeah. So you are,
you're like in this position,
you're sort of UNC cancelable there's you don't have all the trappings
that everybody else has in terms of like sponsors and people coming after you,
you just have subscribers.
Yeah. This was, uh, a conscious decision because, uh,
I saw it coming a while ago. The, uh, what they call cancel culture thing.
When you guys get hit with it first. Yeah.
Out of all the people that have ever heard of,
because when you guys had that homeless person who said he wanted a,
what did he say? He wanted rape.
Condos, rice, condos, rice, and the queen of England. And the first lady, I,
I gotta, I gotta say something about that though.
We had just gotten to satellite radio from FM radio. Yeah. And to us,
this was like, all right. It opens up a whole new world of what we can do.
So I thought what a better place to just showcase a homeless
person.
Let's see what rantings and ramblings come out of a homeless person's mind.
Yeah. So bring 'em up in studio, put 'em in front of a mic and let, 'em go off.
It's satellite. It's not no FCC rules and regs.
And the guy starts talking about crazy stuff and,
and raping political figures and, uh, the queen of England.
And we think it's hilarious because you're getting that insight.
You're getting into the mind of a,
a crazy homeless guy on the street and the hits the fan.
Oh my God. Condo, Lisa Rice,
that brings the sex thing in and the race thing and all that.
And they lost their mind. And we were like, oh, we're getting fired again.
Like, we're gonna get fired for this. What, what hap.
You didn't get fired, but you guys got suspended for yeah. For.
How long we got suspended for, uh, I think it was a month.
I think that was a month suspension from satellite radio.
But we were still at K rock in New York. Yeah. Doing that show in the morning.
Cuz we used to do both.
Yeah. We used to go across with the microphones. I did that with.
You guys. We did the.
Walk over. We do terrestrial and then we would,
we would broadcast live as we were walking down New York city with Mike's and
comics and we would go to the.
Other studio. Yeah.
We would do things occasionally like rich VO would go into a diner or something.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and just start doing stand up. Yes.
In front of the customers. It's hilarious. Cringe, standup cringe, standup.
These people don't know what's happening and stupid big club soda.
Kenny would announce them. Ladies and gentlemen, they're looking like they're,
you know, it's gonna been like a mass shooting is gonna start. And uh,
it was hilarious.
You guys were the birth of podcasts.
It a podcast on the radio. Yeah. We didn't know it at the time.
We didn't know what a, nobody knew what a podcast podcast was,
but it was bunch of guys that you find funny, you like hanging out with. Yeah.
Talking about anything. And that seems to be what the formula is. Yeah.
You guys figured it out first because every other radio show that I did,
like if I did stern or anything else you did, it was very formatted regimen.
Yeah. Time. Like he had some things, he wanted talk.
He wanted to talk to me about fear factor.
He wanted to talk to me about the UFC had questions about this and you know,
it's always like, and.
Then you have a call in and then celebrity guests. And he,
he had it all like very smooth.
You guys would just bring a bunch of people in. Yeah.
And then Patrice would start talking and bur would start talking and Ari would
start talking. And it was just chaos dude. And we were all just having fun.
Just having fun. Yeah.
When you have a room of those guys,
no de Apollo and Patrice, God rests his soul Norton and bill Burr,
Norton, uh, all these guys, Colin Quinn,
they're all in a room. You can't lose like,
like as people will hear it and say, holy, that was one of the funniest shows.
And it's like, what show? The Anthony show? So,
so people remember the name of the show. Yeah.
But all these other guys are delivering this amazing, funny comedy. Uh,
so it worked that way. And we,
we embraced that and just started bringing these comics, uh,
back on in different combinations cuz you know, better than anyone,
some of the funniest stuff you'll ever hear are guys on each other.
Yeah. And, and, and when someone was in, we called it being in the barrel,
you know, and that could consist of wearing a shirt.
You come in wearing a shirt and Patrice goes, what the?
What kinda shirt is that you wearing? What the, where the you get.
And now everyone's on your shirt. Now you are sitting there going,
you're looking at all the comic zone. What can I use to get this off me?
<laugh> so you'd have to on boss' teeth or right. You know, always. So,
so it was this constant battle to get the off of
you. Yeah. And it was funny every time.
And you guys were so great at letting the comics just go wild.
And I put any restrictions on anybody and not try to control the conversation.
Just let it have fun. Just let it.
Breathe. Yep. A lot of shows,
a lot of hosts and this is something you do that is fantastic and rare in
the business. Let your guest talk, let them, and if you have a guest,
a room full of guests, let them have fun. If, if you hear funny going on,
a lot of people, their ego gets in the way. Yeah. And they feel, Hey,
it's my show. My name's on the Marqui. I have to jump in and say something.
If something funny's happening back off, leave it the alone.
It's it's gonna be great. People are gonna love it. And they're gonna go, oh,
that was on the Anthony show. So it doesn't really matter. Who's saying it.
Yeah.
Yeah. You guys had figured it out. It really is the birth of podcast. And I,
I learned a lot from doing that show and I also learned that I wanted to do it
because I, yeah, when I would do your show, I was like, God,
I wanna do a show like this. I wanna do something like this because it was,
it was, you know, when I did regular radio, if I did on tour, I would say, ah,
that may be fun to do a regular radio show. But then I would be like,
they will never hire me. I will say something stupid. I'll get fired.
This is not gonna work out for me. But I do your show and I'd be, huh,
I'd be like, this is this I can, I think I can do this. I think I can do.
I think.
I can do this. I was paranoid because I never went to school for radio.
I was in construction for, until my early to mid thirties, dude. Yeah.
I got into radio late. And my impression was always,
if I didn't know the alloy of the metal in the transmitter antenna,
there's no way you're getting into radio.
Like I thought you had to know all this. It,
that they taught you in radio school.
And the fact of the matter was these jocks were constantly looking for somebody
that was entertaining. Yeah. You never realize, I never realized how, how, uh,
desperate a lot of these jocks are for somebody that could make people laugh.
Uh, and.
Someone with very interest too,
someone it's interesting who could talk about different things. Talk.
About a lot of different things. You know, sometimes you gotta talk out your.
Like you almost kind of know what it's about.
For sure. <laugh> but this, this,
the other thing about like what you guys did was you created a
safe place for men. Like where you could just be a can.
Idiot. One of the last bastions of.
That's the thing it's like, there's a lot of men out there,
but there's not a lot of entertainment. That's geared towards men.
And one of the things that comes up on my podcast,
when the advertising people get to talk and they're like, Jesus Christ,
he's got like 94% men. Like what is going on here? This is crazy. I'm like,
they're not represented. They're not, men are not represented. It's like,
I don't know what the number is of regular television,
but it's not geared towards men. No, not at all. It's there's some,
there's like the talk and the view.
And there's a lot of these shows that are geared towards women.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> but it turns like a man show. You can't have a,
like a male oriented show on network, tell television, it would be toxic.
It's a personal affront to feminism and women. And regardless,
it's just men being men. I don't know where this it's weird. Right.
I don't know where this idea came from that in the past, even couple of decades,
which, you know, relative to a tortoise or a may fly,
you know, it, it, it VA how long, a period of time that is.
But in that period of time, we,
as humans were supposed to have physically and mentally evolved to this
point where men don't still want to talk about and cars and
lifestyle stuff, and guns bash each other guns. Of course. Like we,
I, I think there are people that actually think we,
we have evolved out of that. You know why, instead.
Of being, there's a lot of brainwashed,
a lot of men that are hand packed and they work in some terrible job or human
resources breathing down their neck. Ugh.
And they have neutered themselves and they put themselves into this position of
like this sort of like non man and then non man.
Yeah. And then because of that, they, they chastise other free men, like,
look at this, this is toxic masculinity and it's fine. It's form.
And they say all these crazy things, like we can't be you,
you're not free it doesn't.
And it's also equated somehow or another with cruelty, with being a bad person.
Yeah.
With being a person just by joking around or doing the things that we
like to talk, talking about the things that we like to talk.
About. Yeah. Yep. Uh,
I hear punching down a lot is a bad thing. That was your whole show. Yeah.
That was the entire show.
The entire 20 year history of the Anthony show.
There was never a punch that got past the 180 degree.
You.
You guys don't get enough credit. I really,
I really say I say it every time I can.
That you were the inspiration for podcasts without.
A doubt. It really is. For what I, I think for what Howard did for the,
the shot jock genre in radio,
we kind of were right at that precipice of, of radio and podcast.
Yes. Uh, when,
when that happened and I think what we were doing was better suited to a podcast
than it was a radio show. Yeah.
I think so, too. But it was a great radio show.
Too though, but it was a great radio show. It's just.
The problem is the suits. Yeah. The problem was not the,
the problem was the suits. The problem is people go, Hey, Hey, Hey, you can't.
This is like, meanwhile, did you just see what happened? Everyone was crying,
laughing that's entertainment.
Yeah. That's what they want. That's it, it, it got to a point where early on,
even when I got in, which was again, late in the game,
but early on in the eighties and nineties, uh,
all they gave a about were ratings.
If you had ratings and you did something stupid, you'd get this,
uh,
slap on the wrist in public and behind the door with the GM and the PD and all
the other management people, they'd be like, oh my God, that was great.
Great job. Oh, look, take off a week. Paid what? Say you're suspended.
And that's it. They really did this. And we, we went through a few of those and,
and it turned into,
they really did get mad and they really started suspending you without pay
and firing you. And these were these suits, like you say,
that just didn't understand the talent end of the business anymore. And,
and when radio stations were owned by, uh, mom and pop operations, we,
we were at w AAF up in, uh,
Massachusetts and it was owned by Zappas communications.
I met Zappas. I met the guy, uh,
when we went to infinity broadcasting, there was no Mr. Infinity <laugh>,
there was Mel Carn and there was all the suits from C big.
They got real big and CBS has affiliates.
And they also deal in laundry detergent with this subsidiary.
And like you say something and baby diapers don't sell. Like,
that's how, when it got really up and personalities,
weren't able to do what they do anymore,
because now you're up their sales in the burger industry. And, you know,
Zappas owned a radio station. Yeah.
And he loved when his radio station got ratings.
That was all it was to it. Now it's all a conglomerate.
Catch new episodes that Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog JRE videos on Spotify, including clips,
easily seamlessly switch between video and audio experience
on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
unload episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.